I support cast my name is Hisham azuz
and today in a bit late with Martin
Smith who is the founder and MD of
talent drive thank you for joining me
thanks nice to be and just to set the
scene we're in a place called a club
which I recently signed up to in one of
their meeting rooms and a bit fancy in
that it's very fancy
right sparkling water yeah I wanted to
have somewhere where one I can do
podcasts a bit more flexibly and it's
actually a bit of a nice place as
location so really excited so and Martin
we're always like to start as you know
how did you end up in recruitment my
friend I've always wanted to be a
recruiter now well everyone I think most
people there are on this podcast for
sure say a similar thing in terms of
falling into it a little bit so yeah I
just I've finished at University and 20
I didn't wanted to do no you know I did
Sport Science in English okay so glorify
go into a PE teacher but I didn't happen
so yeah I just I I wanted to work in
London I knew there wasn't many jobs
down in sleepy pool I'm from in Dorset
so I signed up to load of rhetorics and
all sorts of different things and you
know their rhetoric I didn't at the time
yeah and then I had all these different
meetings in conversation with some real
characters who are honest with you and
then lucky and I've landed a business in
London that was kind of in sort of
start-up mode it was a couple years old
and I was sort like the fourth person to
join really well so it was quite new and
it was in I've seen procurement supply
chain which I never even heard the word
procurement before so I was just like
what hell's this yeah and then just sort
of went from there really but it was it
was quite cool because it was kind of
blank piece of paper there wasn't much
of a database yeah sort of go in and
find your market what made you pick I I
liked like that startup feel not
completely startup but you know couple
years experience has some Tremayne for
people may that's pretty intense yeah
yeah absolutely it was a real small
office just off Fleet Street and it was
like that the lady I joined was
fantastic like she's a great great
MD but it was yeah it's quite intense at
times you know when it's going well know
where to hide yeah 100% yeah that's it
as it was a small toilet down the
hallway but there wasn't much room
they'd say yeah we did that grote
father-son time I left it probably got
to about 18 to 20 so yeah it's going
well yeah okay so just to set the scene
then so you have so that was your first
job in recruitment and you work there
Croton from circa for years yeah yeah
and circa four years in the new when
internal yeah and then you went back to
agency and then now how long was that
for again the student back about four
and a half years 1/2 years and then now
you've setup on your own and how many
months you in just comment six months
six months start November's yeah okay so
nearly lot of you nine years an agency
yeah nearly ten years all together and
then office assistant internal as well
right yeah I guess interested me yes I'm
Pat this yeah it's an interesting
pattern okay so first first things first
then have you as have you always done
perm contract mix or mainly perm him a
little bit in contracting more recently
before I went on my own but maybe part
yeah yeah okay cool so let's just and
think a bit about obviously early days
in recruitment right before and we move
on but obviously didn't have much of an
idea as to what was gotten to see a
business that was willing to grow a bit
of a start-up you had obviously direct
access to the MD the business owner
that's something that I really found
valuable and something that I really was
drawn to so how were your first 12
months in recruitment I'm always
interested to ask people about that if
you remember yeah yeah cuz well I mean
the first three months were tough and
like really tough I think I'd seen some
people around me that used to talk about
all you'll get your first dealing in the
first like four to eight weeks that was
like it seems to be the benchmark there
and week ten and I still hadn't landed a
fee and I was just thinking is this for
me am i annoying good I was living my
own and some little box flat in in North
London and obviously not lot my mates
were in London at the time so it got a
little bit lonely at the end and and the
people that I was around me were more
experienced recruiters so they've kind
of been there seen it done it
so I was the sort of the
Roger coming in the first few months are
really tough I've managed to win some
jobs early on but I just couldn't seem
to like what did you go straight into BD
maybe six days yeah yeah straight in on
the phones on my first day first
afternoon I remember like so I had this
client I was calling and I'd let you
calling the switchboard and she was my
boss was like now find out who their
bosses and find out who their bosses and
tell me and I'll literally call this
somebody back about 12 but it's great
you know what it was so so Oh 100% from
the deep end and that would always be my
so advice to people like throwing the
deeper it's okay to mock up so it's okay
to fail I think that's a really
important lesson that I learned and I
think I've seen so many people I've
trained and they they want to make sure
the first calls like a perfect you have
that performance narration but it's not
like that at all so first you monster
tough then I landed my first first fear
after three months almost to the day
being there which was properly yeah
campaign bula I can do this good and
then the next few months were really
good and has some traction but then I
had a lot like a double-dip like a dip
again and after about six months and I
was kind of back to the same bit as its
kind of mum from one month to couldn't
seem to find candidates counts of
dropping out the process and whitewall
you know why would you not go for the
role you can get sometimes very
emotionally invested in a project
especially the beginning yeah absolutely
because you see him take it personally
yeah you really do an idea and I was
always amazed at the job so that was
tough but I think kind of got to like
month 9 month 10 and I started getting a
few consult of consistent months under
my belt of making fees and then it was
going yeah it sort of clicked from there
really
okay nice so a quick one before we move
on from that there may I'll be really
curious because it's probably something
that you really had to cultivate for
your career now but I guess how did you
how did you why did you continue or why
did you dig deep because I'm sure in
those early days you fought about
quitting is this for me right yeah so
what what made you push on would you
think the people around me really I
think the people around me they were
very supportive and I think they they
very much kind of said to people at this
this is we've all been there we've yeah
it's part you didn't feel like oh my god
if I don't if I do that a lot I might
lose my job
no no no
my boss was good she had shared real
patience I think hopefully she saw some
potential me yeah and and invest a lot
of time and lot of effort and a lot of
it was on the job it wasn't like pulling
me off desk and going in a room and
training okay just try that cool again
or do another call and I think that's
the real key thing when you you know
when you fall off your bike get up again
a ride it's cliche but yeah I think it's
so trying I think me looking back as
well and why my director continued to
push directions was I I was willing to
learn if that makes sense like I was he
very easily you can slip into I've done
a deal that I know I'm doing now yeah
but you know I mean something you have
been willing to get back up but and then
having the humility to go actually yeah
I'm still very only on star blows to
learn it's it's okay to Mesa getting
that and that's all part of the learning
journey and I think for me as I say I
saw people around me that were being
successful and I thought I want a piece
of that and yeah I'm naturally like a
competitive guy yeah I want to do well
in sport or my personal life or whatever
and I just felt well no I can't fail at
this I don't wanna fail and yeah
absolutely and I think that's that help
yeah okay so then your time there then
what was the sort of route did you just
continue billing did you manage anyone
by the time you left or what was there
to help me out there yeah what was the
sort of journey in that business so I
think journey the business was if you if
you build money you then start having
people to almost take them on that
journey with you and then give them jobs
and then they start building then you
get more and more people which
necessarily would say there's no right
or wrong with that but just cuz you're a
good biller doesn't always make me
manager so yeah basically consultant
builds about 18 months then I had like a
junior resource so the work for me and
another sort of twelve months had
another headcount come and join and then
I think I had about seven people really
okay so yeah that's really interesting
mate so then let's unpack that a bit
then yeah I'm sure and then did that
full of the same suit when you left
internal and went back agency did that
sort of follow us it wasn't the same the
growth wasn't the same because we were
targeting more experienced hires in my
last business but the first business
were kind of like organic growth ok
graduates upwards yeah all right cool so
before we get into that then yeah that's
really interesting so firstly may always
like to ask billons wise how did you get
on may seem loves he did all right if
only went that direction yeah you what I
probably did I was thinking about it's
the way in this morning I probably did
about 120 okay once it was a
Berryman that's kind of nine months
rather than twelve and then year to
about 150 and they kind of incrementally
went up from there it continued to go up
the break the 200 came up yeah I did
that was came up that was yeah yeah
managed to do that by end of year three
so that was yeah and then what was your
best year there just under 400 okay
didn't hit for Demark and was that in
that place that was in that yeah okay
that's okay cool that's interesting so
first thing then let's just let's just
because what you just shared that let's
just talk a bit about your you looking
back now yeah how do you think that you
continued to go in that direction if
that makes sense in this first sort of
segment of your career what do you think
that was down to a few key points that
youth that come to mind as to how you
got to that point so I think the first
one it might sound bit strange as I was
quite selfish which actually had an
adverse effect on me makes complete
sense but then I was a crap boss yeah I
wasn't great yes I was just like no I'm
focused on my billing and me develop
yeah yeah yeah and other I was quite
good at feeding my team I perhaps didn't
I know I didn't give them the attention
they needed and certainly when you were
graduate and been there myself and it's
quite a lonely place yeah I don't got
invested enough time but yeah you got me
selfish and and and when you say selfish
I mean by that selfish in terms of your
time okay whether it's given to other
people at focusing on your own fees
making sure that they are always kind of
on target I think that's that always
should be your number one sort of focus
particular when you're like a bilities
when you're just building yeah yeah
absolutely so selfish it's a really
selfish of your time yeah really honed
them on your Billings and okay anything
else
some of the cliche ones but like good
work ethic I mean you know no surprise
if you're first in the door last out the
door
you're probably gonna move on the top
bill is in a company I think generally
that's good I think the main thing for
me and what my differentiate and I'll
probably talk about a few times is being
authentic okay so authentic with
everyone you're interacting whether it's
people around you whether it's your your
your candidates recline whatever I think
people buy into that they don't endorse
they can almost smell the sales [ __ ]
that a lot of Reuters kind of give so I
think if you're authentic and a bit
genuine with your candidate know when
did you start realizing that though
because I fit that's quite good
self-awareness to that wasn't in the
first job though no stay really my first
job is essentially selfish Billa Billa
Billa
make loads of money let my team up it
leave you know LOV that was animate sort
of the first part of my sort of agency
journey but I think with the time it's
probably when I was in house and I was a
bit like okay and he saw the other side
okay cool alright cool so next thing
then before we move on to that cuz I'd
love to get your your experience on the
internal side and about the managing
team thinks there'll be there'll be a
lot of people listening that and our
good bill is or wanted become managers
or our managers right now and struggling
I mean you hear all the time I wasn't a
billing manager but you hear all the
time it's one the most difficult job in
the recruitment agency right so knowing
what you now know yeah looking back
you've already identified that he was
very selfish and it was all about you
and your time which meant that your
Billings didn't dip which tip which led
to you not being a great manager right
so how how did you how would you go back
and change that now do you think yes I
think I would empower them to make more
decisions themselves almost that whole
self coaching thing so I think sometimes
they would come to me with a problem and
they already need a solution mmm no
you'd almost talk it through with them
and at the time I would just go and do
this do this and move on crap you just
tell ya answer it was a tell approach it
was like this is what you need to do go
back to you have to do it and it'll be
fine like just do it my way woman and
that's how I my mentality but I think
reflecting back on that I should have
empowered them more to make the
decisions themselves for sure and and
typically nine times out of ten they
come to the same conclusion I would have
anyway yeah but actually a is what
you've been more efficient with the time
and B they feel self empowered that
they've always and they're not relying
on you yeah absolutely yeah but I didn't
do that and tell we let it down my
career and then we're and then anything
around I think it's a quite typical
thing that people trip up on is that you
you have the expectations of the people
around you that you have yourself which
salute isn't that ferry more yeah I
really like well I've done it that way
so you should be able to do that yeah
and you approach it that way yeah that
was my sort of style
did you was you in charge of hiring for
your team was you involved in that I was
involved in the process I mean also be
my my MD it was her decision but we you
know we absolutely had our views and we
were able to sort of be part of that
decision-making I think for me I would
look at people and I still do it today
it's likability if I like someone I say
what the cool things that you look for
I've got like
person if you like the person you invest
time in them and invest time them
they're likely to be more successful so
how would you measure that there and
then interview first five minutes yes
it's a good point first five minutes
kind of kind of bounce of them do I like
them is their smiles is there you know a
bit of a bit of warm bit of charisma
it's something about them but it's more
in their belly because as you say it's
long hours it's lonely at times like
you've got to have a bit of something
about you
yeah and listening to you know all the
people that pin on your podcast today
they've all got something about them the
character they've all got fire in the
belly and you know I think for me that
that's the number one come on load about
that
I think it's no I don't think so I think
you like me saying that yeah personally
you see that fine I belly whatever like
yeah and you cultivate that yeah I mean
there's been people that many names I've
managed that perhaps when I first met
them I've been a bit like I see
something in you
I wouldn't necessarily the first person
I'll go for a beer at the pub but I see
nothing in you and I've within reason
I've been able to sort of manage that
you know how you can communicate with
clients how you send emails to people
how you can come and come across and the
offer is I think to a degree you can but
I'm kind of people before we move on
then just to help me out so when after
you went internal an agency and even
more now starting our own business have
you and have you had to obviously
ultimately build up your market from
scratch or yeah a much yeah yeah
okay so let will touch on that in the
bit then because that is everyone wants
to know about that right so you've done
that when you also got in that role when
you went ain't it again and now I've
seen your own business restricted
covenant stuff like that yeah yeah yeah
okay cool
why did you go internal I'd fallen out
of love with agency what did you fall
out of love him oh I was I just thought
that and and been honest with you like I
just thought every every agency was the
same really it was just transactional it
got to the point where everyone was just
you know organically growing graduates
hires and stuff like that and not
knocking it it's a good approach but
yeah I think for me I just I just fall
out of love I burnt myself out to want
to show you wasn't there so my business
is fought I burnt myself out I do you
mean by that
just I've done so like I'd burn the
Calot both ends and really used to say
like I just literally be I'm in the
office like 8 o'clock in the morning
half 7 whatever I believe in at 7:00
7:30 9 early and for beers or like
trying to social clients and I wouldn't
be getting into a lot half 10 11 I was
doing that almost every night
all four when did you burn out was that
particular let's talk about that I'm TT
you said earlier that you listened to
Ross's journey and yes obviously he
didn't talk about burn now he had the
real traumatic experience which had to
do with that led to the catalyst um
Intel stuff at that yeah but being oh
I'll be honest let me start my own
business also come relate like I'm
already aware of that like it's just me
sheesh you at the moment why it's like
it's it's so easy to say yes to staff
and get into a habit like you got a bit
I'm already aware of like well no I need
to make sure that have enough time my
girlfriend need to make sure I have
enough time to exercise like that's
definitely been my biggest challenge
already like for months it and like
definitely in terms of health go and
gymnast off that's definitely slats cuz
it's the obviously pendulum has gone way
towards business that make sense to lie
it was a lie
was that just a constant buildup of you
just having those habits and that
routine yeah absolutely I mean I love my
football I play it watch it read about
it whatever and and I used to play for a
team and to initially that was a point
where I kind of neglected that as well
yeah because I was doing such long hours
or something good training and then I
wasn't playing all of a sudden like yeah
so leant towards work yeah absolutely
and I just felt I couldn't really escape
from it and the problem is when you set
a bar high yeah you you you kind of it's
a double-edged sword cause you want to
keep continuing continue pushing because
they're the hours you've done and you've
almost set yourself an expectation in
the office like my boss kind of resume
that's what I was doing and and it just
gets to the point where you know your
team expecting you and do those hours
and you just got to the point where I
was just like I'm done with it I need to
and I just thought the grass was greener
and doing house and enormous gaps it was
it literally just a moment alarm done
yeah I was I was I was an event in
London vividly remember where I was is a
Christmas and I would there was like a
networking event thing was get it was
really cool really good event and I'll I
just got to even and I just remember
turnaround so I was just like I need to
I need to have a break or do something
and then and that was it and then I went
internal and decision yeah
yeah okay which happens a lot you see a
lot yeah yeah and what just to be clear
on that but move on to that because I
think it's interesting like what was you
trying to escape from do you not I mean
yeah what was you trying to get out of
it was almost the pressured almost put
on myself
yeah by being in that environment that's
interesting wasn't it so my button like
my boss thinks wrong she wasn't
absolutely yeah yeah so so I guess you
you must have fought then at that point
if I'm gonna stay in this then it means
that I have to put these out yeah it's
to get there yeah the returns that I won
and in my head I was needed like I can't
do that sustainable in my head
25 years old just just got a mortgage as
well so putting that yeah that that sort
of chain around your neck as well that
pressure and I just thought no I need to
I need to do something different and
actually agency oh sorry in house will
give me an opportunity to have more
work-life balance and my perception at
the time was very much a nine-to-five
job which yeah turned out not to be but
okay no I think sharing that man yeah
that's really interesting okay so how
long was you in in house recruitment for
just over a year and wasn't one of your
clients
yeah no the first one was an old
internal recruitment lady that when
in-house okay and or winters new come be
sorry and and the other one she was at
guess she was a coca-cola okay so that
was their case and then you worked for
coca-cola yeah work coca-cola yeah okay
so as an internal recruit then you'll
role was to what
well I initially went in there to run
what's called group functions H RIT all
the central staff but within a few
months the person was running the
procurement supply chain left the
business so guess what the person that
new procurements apply to in background
so I got sort of put with pretty much
everything apart from marketing that I
was running so you had to fill all the
vacancies and that yeah I had a team
that a really good seen that work for me
I was really lucky how big was a team
there's three of them so that they were
really good and then someone came in
picked up the group functions and I ran
with procurement supply changed slowly
because it wasn't managed for doing
obviously pretty much everything so yeah
yeah I did that for 12 months so let's
just go over the highlights of that I'd
love to know obviously I feel like the
majority of the people listening will be
agency and how was it
in Coco's off system the business that
you work for you got your salary not
firstly was there any incentive for you
to fill these vacancies at all was there
a bonus game and no nothing it was your
base salary
there was a yearly bonus but it wasn't
that wasn't how many people okay yeah so
what was the actual experience tell us a
bit about the experience like what was
it like being in the business that
you've worked for blah blah blah like
what just what was the sort of overall
experience would you say how did you
describe it look I met some amazing
people and one one thing I kind of
learned there and learnt so much there
but one thing I learned there is brand
loyalty like I saw so many people that
are almost sort of man and boy or girl
and woman like just been coke people for
years and years and years just develop
through the power of brand yeah
absolutely that they were there for the
brand they were there for the love of
the job and there were so many people
like that that I learnt so much from and
I've got a lot of respect for them yeah
and that's interesting in the time yeah
but I think I think in terms of its
definite not a nine-to-five job
education people think that so you have
to put the hours in it's the same amount
of graft and stuff but I kind of
describe it as you and barely on this
thought but like you're using your brain
a lot when you're in-house mmm so when
you're an agency recruiter it's all
around emotion intelligence all around
that body language communication style
people buying into people that's it that
sales hmm when you're in-house you're
actually that that's not what it's about
it's much more around kind of strategic
visions as setting up strategies and you
know what's your USP what's your
branding gonna be when you graduate
fairs you know what kind of talent
attraction tools you're going to use to
get people into the business yeah it was
much more geared around that that's
interesting um and and that's great how
did that impact in the recruiting you
didn't recruit as much that was the
challenge yeah my biggest sort of
frustration was when you're an internal
recruiter and not in all cases but in my
case I was focusing so much of my time
almost about having meetings about
meetings you know nemedian approach and
I was so many times where I would be
literally sat in a room amazing staff
demote you know graduate scheme strategy
or whatever it may be but I wasn't doing
I wasn't gone out there recruiting the
people I'm sitting there going well I've
got 25 vacant list of 25 vacancies and
all the hiring managers knocked on the
door I was gonna say who is you then
getting pressure from the home at the
walk partner des and that's that's the
biggest key your agency you can hide
behind yeah
it's gone it's gone directly or it's
come from nother agency or whatever but
when you're when you're internal there
there you're accountable you can't just
go oh well another agency will fill it
you've got to fill the role because
they're walkin partial deaths every day
going I'm going to Stevie's Martin
what's going on and how did it feel
making placements but not getting a fee
yeah that that was the realization and
it was tough it was tough it's Italy
when I was doing the more senior end of
supply chain and procurement which
obviously a big you know six-figure
salary rolls so really really great
people that I hired in there and and and
lot them is still there which is awesome
but yeah there was no money on the van I
love it yeah absolutely
yeah it was it was really tough and that
was assuming he's like realization
moments but like I was I was up in the
they've got a site up in morpeth which
is it it's up in new cast all right I'm
from my family for the Northeast okay
more purpose like a really sleepy part
of up in the north of England and I
remember hiring the new supply chain
director really like really charismatic
lovely lady she's fantastic
and I remember getting on the train the
way back and I was working out what the
fee would have been if I delivered it
and that was no good that was my moment
I thought I could have made all that no
and I that swen i-news this isn't for me
I cut I shouldn't be calculating what
you feel things you don't do it for that
you don't do it for the money money I
brought up when your internal you're
doing it for the passion of working for
the brand yeah and and that wasn't mine
so put one before we move on yeah yeah
you said it a few times now and I like
it what where's this sort of
decision-making come from because like
I'm quite the same yeah yeah you seems
like you you've had like you've got to a
point realize some in and then chat and
then you're like right I'm yeah an
action have you always been like that
yeah if I realized something it then
kicks into my gut my gut says and I've
got yeah yeah yeah and that's been I
guess think about me my thought process
round one yeah I'm not can just really
relate with that because that's
definitely how I got to this point yeah
understand just complete guy instinct
and make an incision
yeah and he's thinking what's the worst
that can happen yeah but you know with
Co it was an amazing experience that
people they were fantastic
yes it's around the heart then anyone
listening right now I didn't see who's
thinking is a grass greener there's
businesses now where you can work for an
agency and then freed
sigh internal have more impact on talent
strategy that all the all these things
now which is really exciting right but
from your experience how would you what
would people what should people think
about coming from agency so I'd like you
have gone into internal role what should
they be thinking about that you maybe
didn't know before you got in there and
now no sort of thing so I think the
variety okay when you're an agency
recruiter obviously you've got more than
one clients you've got a variety don't
tear that for content no absolutely ever
granted I think I think if you're if
money is one of your number one drivers
and don't do internal yeah you know you
get a solid salary you get a high basic
salary likelihood an agency but don't
don't do it for the monetary reasons
you're doing it to maybe go into a
different career maybe what interesting
going into HR a great Avenue for a lot
of internal recruiters to go down so I
think if you're a very money driven
person there's absolutely nothing wrong
with you might you're more there's a
very good chance experienced that moment
where you're like yeah I'm a good two
feet could have been yes I've just hired
like ten hundred K people into this
business I would have made X amount of
commission yeah
and I haven't got that if you're if
you're thinking of that when you're in
that role you're in trouble
yeah hundred percent yeah okay you did
it the wrong reason okay so variety if
you're really driven by money think
twice about it really understand what
you're getting input blah blah and it's
a good Avenue to potentially get HR or
other avenues and maybe it's the talent
strategy that you all this stuff at that
that fairness was that I think there's a
there's a preconception that they seem
like are the gatekeepers and I think
that's a really unfair like you hear
some people say about all they're like
fail recruiters when they're in-house
yeah that's really unfair label some of
the majority of the best recruiters not
not all obviously but the majority of
some of the best recruiters I've ever
known have been like internal people and
also I think the other thing as well as
sometimes people think all the pace is
different like agency paces everything
right but you can also work in lots
there's lots of clients that I represent
now where I'm working with their
internal recruiter and they've got real
pace so okay so a final thing actually
before I forget yeah how how then was
your experience of agency recruiters
that's always interesting that I spoke
to some yeah ladies recently from
trapeze and asked them what's the
typical thing that a recruitment
recruitment concern would just do wrong
or just do to piss off the internal and
you know I mean like what what that
must've been interesting so what was the
insight there now been on the other side
of the fence and going oh my god like
this is bad or you know I mean I've got
quite a few links a message from some my
competition agency again [ __ ] you're
in house do you know what and that was
one of the things when I was when I was
on that train thinking about ashes is
for me that was one things was go from a
head because I must admit my experience
when I was in house of the agencies some
of the agencies not all sorry some of
the agencies I was partner with weren't
great
they were that very stereotypical frou
series that we'll see what can stick
really it was that it was very what does
that mean it was really that it was
quite transactional they were just you
know I've gone briefing calls all the
time again but gone Breivik all
sometimes and I knew that hi Madge is
looking for that pink elephant you look
something doesn't exist and then the HTS
we will go yeah yeah and then the core
I'm thinking guys we're looking to pay
peanuts for something that there's it's
not realistic and I'd really empower
them to kind of you know push back a
little bit about ever did so I think
that whole can consultative approach
which you know I'm a big champion of I
didn't really see that a lot again I
kind of thought I could do that better
and I know that sounds a bit arrogant
but I just thought I can do something
that I don't think a lot of the people
could do what was your worst experience
what spring someone like what was the
worst thing you like oh my god is this
actually real so they saw my god yeah
yeah I can tell your story so there was
a procurement role which obviously I
wasn't I didn't go out to agency quite
thing I kind of knew what I was doing
and and they contacted me and I said
thanks like but no thanks that moment
keep in touch Dada
then they'd contacted the lie manager
yeah then they contacted his boss then
they'd contacted HR yeah then they had
sent a CV of someone that used to work
at the business and to them to her
manager mmm so they'd especailly sent
the CV or someone that worked at their
business for years ago then they cut
their nigh content and saying don't do
that and they said I didn't send an
email so I then had to forward the email
to them saying you did and here's is and
also the used to work here so it was
just like what you're doing not the way
and that's and you do take a lot of
lesson from that I'm quite lucky I guess
in terms of a USP that because I've been
gobby again to my authentic you've got
to be a bit real with them because
there's no point I'm saying thanks for
no thanks and you just start spamming
the Seavey's because you're never gonna
get anywhere so to sum that up there
that's real interest in what should a
recruiter right now not do to piss off
an internal career like what should they
not be doing do not has a minute like
what should they stay clear of this is
what spamming TVs in really that's the
most common thing people do here 100%
you just you just like every other
recruiter yeah so I think it's trying to
position another way it's the whole
active listening piece which I always
encourage my team to do is actually
listen to what they're saying you know I
was when I started out and stuff I
always remember the internal recruiters
or even the line manager to say call me
in a week and I'd literally dereyes a
call and a 9:30 follow I know it sounds
rebase it but literally yeah quite a few
people have said that and then they hit
a voicemail and then okay when can I
call you next Tuesday yes following it
no it's really interesting to say that
because the ladies that repeats also the
same thing and with would you say them
to people that are really the internal
recruiter is the key to everything they
said they the line manager might really
rate you but they're like sorry like you
just have this is our process how to
respect it would you really advise
recruiters and to really keep gunning
and getting the opportunity to speak to
the internal recruiter rather than just
keep trying to hit them with CVS blah
blah blah but always try and drive
towards that opportunity to where they
can build a bit of relationship or they
can speak to them rather than keep
trying to hit in with relevant cv yeah
you know I mean yeah I did to promote at
end of the day the internal recruiter
are gonna be the gatekeepers they're
gonna be one that runs that that contra
that Pearson so there's no point
antagonizing them yeah if you're relying
on purely growing your business through
working with internal recruiters that's
probably not gonna give you as much
fruition as yeah still engaging with you
in my case like the procurement director
yeah
or HR directors or whatever so I think
almost do it's a two-pronged attack but
I respect the internal recruiters and
then come back to the line managers with
something not just who's a CV whew it's
a you know I'm doing a podcast series or
a leadership event or I've interests get
your thoughts on on whatever just come
into it a bit different because you've
got appreciate from an internal speaking
from an internal perspective you know
every agency will come to you with CVS
pros about you so you've got a ton
things are playing diff
before you go at it yes yeah everyone's
just gonna do the same now I think are
two problems that make sense doesn't I
think it's respect the process respect
everyone involved and I think really
focus on yeah delivering value not just
looking like anyone else and I think
really if you if you get that hiring
manager to speak about you in the right
way because you've followed up we've
spoken about industry things you have
just wasted their time you haven't
irritated them and you've got that
person then speaking internally highly
of you that's only gonna benefit then
your internet you know I mean that makes
sense doesn't it yes absolutely and cool
so then on the back of see your train
journey I see it I'm going back agency I
want to make some more money okay and
then and then you did that for for how
low and a half years yeah and then to
just frame up the journey its back into
the same market yep so then you join as
a consultant I'm assuming no I joined a
senior manager so the the business was
was was one so the MD and an owner of
the organization so yeah they had a
sister brand that did HR recruitment and
the lady run that was phenomenal
recruiter is a phenomenal recruiter and
yeah it was just just the two of us and
we kind of built it out from there so
brought in all my kind of relationships
that I've had and and you know dusting
off the the book from sort of a year or
two ago and develop from there and grew
it so that was really nicely we got to
about ten by the time I left really so
from two of us we how many in your so I
kind of managed what I managed three or
four people of that okay yeah that's
interesting
and then and then the did you some
follow a similar path from some of the
billing performance or have that guy
yeah yeah ish I sort of yeah you one was
like steady because I was sort of
growing market that wasn't there yeah
which had its challenges but yeah year
two three before what were great it's
really good yeah really happy that do
more than 400 no no didn't sadly ok yeah
no but yeah that's good that's really
interesting so I think the key thing
that I'd love to talk about there and
then sorry so then obviously then you
left there to start your own business
I'll shoot a few months in now and then
even in your business now you've had to
again build up yep a business straight
there nuclei
Lyons yeah yeah I love you okay cool
let's talk about that how have you
typically done that then if you've if
you've had to do that after the internal
piece you're doing that now you can talk
about how you've done it now if you want
but how have you typically focused on
building a desk building a team that how
have you talked to me about that so I
think a lot of it comes from the
candidate like journey essentially so a
lot of people that I now work with were
people that in in procurement language
were like buyers you know back in 2009
when I started out so I started on their
journey then I followed them through cuz
think a lot of recruiter would just look
at a can as a commodity mmm are they
good for that role or not and then you
know yeah exactly so it's the long term
peace for me which I think's really key
so if I look now a lot of the clients
that I work with and have worked with in
the last few years these are all people
majority of which that as I say there
were buyers it was senior buyers you
know just start out as hiring managers
and I always say to my team the
barometer of success isn't making the
fee it's that person will come to you as
the first point of contact either
they're hiring off they're looking and
that's all a good thing to measure and
that's the basis of what of what I
measure success on so I think for me a
lot of it was as I say really good
candidates that I'd keep in touch we
have a network with and continue that
relationship going and that was the core
of my kind of business development you
still have to do I mean certainly the
last six months like job spotting and
chasing leads up and stuff like that but
it's it's building that relation with
candidates and trying to find a solution
to what they're doing and was you aware
that you was doing this early on do you
know I mean no I wasn't know so when did
you really double down on that I think
it was probably when yeah it's probably
about 2/3 is in when I want a really big
contract with with a retail business
yeah and got all that all the jobs it
was amazing and it was purely from like
hiring like a 40k sort of senior bar
into their business so and they were
like brilliant you can do that you could
do everything and I was like why no like
that so well well because the internal
recruitment was like we got feedback
from the candidate about the experience
and it was great and dadada and we
haven't had that before because even
like really basic things like I met all
my candidates so like the other agents
you just never met their candidates and
you did that and you took them for
coffee and you ran them through the
recruitment process and you were there
at the end of the phone sounds really
simple people listeners go and that's
obvious but not a lot of amazing how
many people don't do it
and that was the differentiator and that
allowed me to build it and then I kind
of self reflected and put another train
journey and and realized that actually
kind of candidate is king and that's
that's the way I'm gonna develop a
business and that's why anyone listening
right now how can they start how can
they start approaching it this way you
know I mean cuz there's a lot of
impatient people out there they've got
their managers going I need you to get
on the phone more and you need to win
more clients bla bla bla but how can how
can they start cultivating this because
clearly where you are now starting your
own business it's clearly paid off for
you how did you go about making sure
that you your team made sure that the
kind of experience was on point and and
started to really double down and
cultivate that you know I'm in yeah
absolutely
meet you can that's definitely the first
thing where possible I appreciate for
those listening that I've got
international markets and the based in
in London whether they can join our
video have that face time with them know
whether it's as you save a video or face
to face like meet your canit's and I say
to my team find your top ten top ten
canit's that you're currently working
with that realists you're going to make
the business money you know people are
gonna your clients are going to be
interested in and obsess over them
relate to them find ways to support them
as I say it's not just about the
transaction about the recruitment is
there a networking event you know even
when I first started I always remember
when I first started in my last business
I actually sent a link to a job I didn't
even have on to a senior guy and he got
the job
so I didn't make the fee because I've
given him that I've know that because I
long term game and now we and then he
became one of my biggest customers
because I'd given him a tip in mavin so
I hadn't won that and made that you know
the ground fee wherever it was ATM fee
I'd supported in that sort of indirectly
and he really respects me for doing that
again it's about being different and I
think that's the real key thing for me
did you have challenges like that story
for example light did you have
challenges internally approaching it
that way
no not at all my last were amazing that
and actually that was one more big
learns if I look at my first person to
work for
and the last business my last MD would
really empower me to do that he talked
about being authentic which is what I
said earlier and be a bit genuine with
people don't just think about the fee
think about the big picture and that was
a real real big loan
that she's interesting that because I'm
just thinking like people listening if
they told their manager that their blood
mate what you did exactly that there's
got to be that internal selling piece
isn't it like squirrel hang them in
there this is what I am serious about
building a long-term recruitment desk I
do want to achieve that go-to person
good and that does involve paying
forward and it does involve doing it
like being genuine or fence it you know
I mean it's a lot it's the long yeah
you're so right it's a long-term vision
of it like ultimately you can transact
you know finally can amazing a job
that's no but if you want to be a little
bit strategic a bit more innovative and
a bit more authentic about it that's the
way to do it it's actually I haven't got
this job on but I've seen this job in
wherever would you be interested yet
they're gonna be like Jesus this guy
isn't really just nice as genuine
yeah and that really that really gets
people to draw to you and that's why you
know you get that repeat business back
and that's how you build a desk and then
they refer you to friends and the word
of mouth right it doesn't matter what
sales environment or it and that's
powerful it's so powerful and that's
that's how I managed to build the market
because they would go you need to talk
to Martin Smith like it's under their
business and and it just sort of
snowball effect from there because
senior people interact with senior
people and then especially as yeah
absolutely
and so before before we go on to you
start your own business and and that
journey so far and authentic right said
it quite a few times
what does actually mean genuine real
real with people Manas you know transmit
yourself being yourself that's it like
for me I don't know I've seen it in
businesses where people have tried to be
someone else and the bet it's one of its
best bit of what better advice I ever
got was in the first business and one of
the senior people came out to me and
said don't try and be you know that
personal that person pick bits from
different people that you like and then
create your own and and that's so
important so I think for me being
authentic with people just me you get
better engagement I think so just be
real be honest if y'all got any jobs to
them I'm got any jobs don't say gonna
call them a week because the likelihood
knows you can't find the job for them or
if they're right in the center of the
location that you recruit in and tell
them you'll call them in a week's time
tell them you work with X wines they're
clients tell them that they're not
hiring at the moment but they might hire
in two months set the expectation the
candor and again they'll they'll value
that how did you start getting your team
and
how did you start getting your team to
be more authentic so I think I think it
came down to being realistic with them
on the phone and managing expectations I
think it's as I say it's a case of you
know you get a good can in your location
tell them you've got some potential
really good jobs or if they're you know
recruiting in from Qatar and you're not
marrying out you know you're not gonna
be able to fill the roles or support
them with recruitment so I think that's
the first thing is to take go meet them
go and understand their needs and just
just try and relate to them like find
some commonalities because in the day
it's people dealing with people and I've
heard it a few times on the podcasts
like recruitment isn't rocket science
it's about interacting with people
people buy into people and I think
that's that's what you do mmm okay have
you always wanted to start your own
business it's always been the back of my
head so we've been a niche I think they
and how many months you in there so just
count to six months okay November so
yeah it was something that I'd always
thought of doing but probably been a bit
scared to do and then I was just scared
the risk you know okay it's your head
it's you know I guess it's everything
you're generating it's it's it's to keep
you on your own right and it's just me
and my own right now
have you found it being on your own
lonely I mean yeah I well I I my clients
now I'll be honest probably like a third
of the people are one-man bands and
wanting to grow their business and I've
said it a few times but there's quite a
few stats out there to back up the 80
percent their equipment industry
employee under 10 staff right so how
have you actually found that being on
you I enjoy me so have you worked so you
work from home you Tommy yeah well go
home and then there's an office share I
do quite close to where I live yet and
so yeah so have you found that in six
months being on your own so yeah so I
think it's about self motivation I think
you just got to try and surround
yourself with good people they don't
have to be directly recruiters just good
people and family and that's friends
bouncing ideas off people because when
you you know when you want to celebrate
success it's important to bounce that
and similarly when you're having a
rubbish day and you're struggling you
need to bounce that off so I think I
think self motivation is the biggest
thing to try and get over when you're
starting your own because like yeah
there's I mean you're not answering Tony
or not yeah you know I was anyone which
gives you freedom but also that lack of
accountability is quite strange at times
yeah so I think I would use self
motivate yourself there so I get two
little benchmarks in the day and this is
this I got this like I bought a home and
I'll be like right okay if I can make X
amount of calls this morning yeah I'll
make myself a nice coffee and then
that'd be like ten minute break things I
kind of do in the day and I've had a
good conversation someone right cool and
yeah it was really weird when I got my
first like fee and on my own it was just
me and I've sat home and the girlfriend
was at work and whatever and I was just
like yeah that's all so would you and so
I literally I call my dad and I was like
dad I got the singing I didn't care in
the garden no ever okay cool cool Malaya
and and that was it and then to fade you
did say that well but yeah no so and
then yeah the no bounce ideas from
people and I quickly got involved in
some like peer to peer groups some
recruitment kind of networking things I
found really valuable so there's what
there's one local to me could evolve and
recruitment leaders in London elite
leader sorry love
so what does that actually involve just
for people cuz I yeah I recommend this
to quite a few people yeah just because
I've been to a few different ones and
yeah I think especially for people like
you it's a great opportunity to meet
other people and so like how it was that
why is that being a benefit to you just
so like peer to peer groups like
bouncing ideas from people and almost
sense checking I'm thinking about doing
this yeah am I crazy or is that a good
idea and just almost having that litmus
test of that sounds good Martin although
that's we didn't is don't do that but I
think I really value that and and I've
you know what when you start in your own
you really show those people really come
out of the woodwork that have shown real
generous to me that have actually been
competitors of mine before and I've been
on ages of people being willing to help
yeah absolutely how can I help and like
good for you start your own all that
like I've been really well to be fair
I've probably experienced the same have
you yeah I think yeah I think I think
particularly on them
LinkedIn lot I think it's such a unique
platform that generally people are will
Intel yeah
well that's like no BS like yeah if
you'd like if you went on tomorrow and
put a poster my girlfriend is in this
position right now but wants to do this
and these help like you're gonna get
help
yeah even if that's like it's just I
think it's such a unique place where
people are willing to do that which I
think it's really cool about there yeah
what's been the biggest challenge for
you probably the self motivation as a
self countered it within reason with
like networking groups but I think
there's still days say when the summer
and like England cricket on or there's
football on or whatever and it's to the
temptation justice outside and enjoy
that so I think self motivation has been
the biggest chance when it's just me and
appreciating the people that I'm calling
I've got day jobs and other things to
worry about yeah but yeah so what have
you got mentors or have you got anyone
holding you accountable yeah yeah I've
so I've been quite fortunate a couple of
people that kind of mentor me and and
again I sort of bounce ideas and what's
that done for you I think it's just give
me the belief really I know that might
sound a bit cheesy but it's give me the
belief that I actually do know what I'm
doing and I can do that and they've been
in that situation well but like what I
was saying earlier when you start out
and you you're kind of picking up ideas
and experience of other people that yeah
I've been there and it's the same when
you run your own business I think having
that reassurance from people saying look
I've been there I've been dating I'm
like getting need to get that fear in
because I need you know the mortgage
being paid and whatever like yeah I've
been there I think that really allows
you to do it and and obviously when she
start getting fees in it snowballs and
then every time I've managed to deliver
something I've had more confidence and
going okay yeah cuz I've been you know
be recruiting the same discipline for
nearly ten years it's like I know how to
recruit people but it's very different
when you're running rowing business and
how long did it take you to get that
first dale do you know what i actually
was really lucky at it i want to
retained simon really and managed to
deliver that in within sort of the first
three or four weeks and how much
retained you do it was like the 25k
retained so just kept me like breathing
a good but how much retained you do as a
business that was you that was anything
i really the rest it was contingent yeah
so i thought hey this is great
everything i'm going to work with you
pitched that purposely yeah i pictured
purposely talk to me i i'd known them
years ago dealt with them recently I'd
known them years ago and it was just
really good timing that they'd gone into
a new business and and I just thought
what was the pitch like why would they
why would they pay retained rather than
contingent well that they didn't have an
internal recruiter okay say no that's
great yeah of course cool so they're
quite an immature function which I think
sometimes can lie to to nail the retains
a little bit more and I just said look I
played more like I'm gonna simplify the
process and I hope you write the
spec's come onto site and i'll run the
assessment with you like no like yeah
also we've only got one HR manager like
great so you pitched it as a dedicated
result dedicate resource of cess over
your brand push all the stuff out on my
own advertising boards I'll do all the
legwork for you and you just pay it in a
lump sum and and that that was really
really great actually that kept me that
sort of got me going first four weeks
yeah it is
yeah thanks it's not it was really good
timing as well that they're just as I
say join this new yeah and obviously
also you have restrictive covenants yeah
you've really had to focus on new yeah
bets and new clients yeah and then have
you approached that then has it been
some of the thing that you spoke about
in terms of trying to leverage your
existing relationships and well that's
been challenging because I haven't been
able to talk to existing relationships
from client or panda so for me it's been
like actually it's been quite fun though
I was talking some about yesterday like
it's actually quite fun be just to let
you go out old school recruitment like
go on the job boards go and understand
like you know I've seen that job now
kicking around LinkedIn for two months I
cannot help you and at honest you I've
been feeding off the dregs a few times
are the feelings to try and get some
traction but actually got to do in you
boy what have you been proactive with
like what would you say has been the
best sort of read to market for you over
the six over the last six months because
there'll be a lot of people listening
there yeah my I'll just died out yeah
thing about starting out but thinking
how what can I do in those six months
covenants that doesn't involve spending
a lot of cash so I kind of checked yeah
so I kind of put it turn it on its head
a little bit because 99% of people you
know I might smear if I'm especially for
Kim supply to have a Creole proverb I
can offer you this is they're gonna get
from every recruiter so I've almost come
to them saying can I find you a solution
so what solution can I offer you and and
you know actually these are people that
can maybe save you money because that's
what the division I do procurement
that's what they're all about
so almost positioning it in a slightly
different way I think that was quite
good with a candidate or with a cabinet
yes you focus on again and can go
commando market absolutely yeah so again
can its King and I generate some some
candidates and new candidates in talk to
about the marketplace and then offer
them as a solution to jobs that had out
there yeah but it was a numbers game
like the last six month for me has been
a numbers game there's none don't get me
wrong there's been nothing particularly
strategic or and I've just been trying
to make make make stuff happen like
churn out like get as many sort of good
talent that you're working with out
there to clients that you can see our on
a higher
and then it's a numbers game and then
I've had a few that gone yeah cool
actually were struggling or and then I
just - to jump on that and deliver which
is which is been really good it's been
fun it's been back to one and joining
one again yeah yeah absolutely
okay and what was I gonna say so what's
the and then is it something that you're
looking to to grow or yeah yeah yeah
definitely like for me I didn't set up
time drive to be a lifestyle business
you know that from day one yeah fair
enough yeah I think if I if I was gonna
do a lifestyle business I probably would
have carried on on the same route I was
doing for another I don't know five or
ten years and and let that sort ride and
then just done it as a lifestyle with
you know maybe I'll do family kids
whatever but yeah for me soon as I knew
I was gonna do it I wanted to have
something that was going to grow quickly
and I could sort of try and try and get
to what I wanted to do so yeah okay
however since starting your own business
I'm always curious about this something
I think that's interesting like how how
has it been how have the relationships
around you been that make sense from a
new challenge right yeah what from-from
life in general like friends
relationships like because again that's
something that people seriously have to
think about do you know I mean yeah I've
had mine I mean I'm four months in and
had my own sort of journey with it yeah
yeah sure so I'd love I'd love to hear a
bit about that like so I think from a
friends point of view they've got like I
don't know wolf of wallstreet images the
cap rate spray us brand money around the
room like you can bring you on in and
sake one and whatever and it's just like
no that's not how it works yeah so
that's been quite fun so any of your
friends business owners I've got one
friend that's a bit yeah yeah yeah
obviously myself a bit and obviously
yeah yeah so so yeah so he gave me some
he gave me some good advice but he said
just don't don't run too quickly like
yeah make sure you do it in a measured
way and somehow that I which again was
was really helpful because he runs his
own manufacturing company so that that
was quite unique to kind of understand
that perspective away from recruitment
yeah but again you know it's bouncing
ideas off a couple of recruitment owners
that were local to me that again games
that you reach out did you know them I
reached out some both yeah reach was the
one was my direct competitor really I've
done a lot of eight yeah a lot of ain't
she calls with and staff and and
actually want the people that empower me
to go out and do it it's like so
how did you that's really interesting
symbol drop to link to message and say
look well we met a few months before it
when I was thinking about doing it okay
oh the conversation hits but did you
reach out before at that point yeah
reached that point and then I said I I
was doing it I reached out to Gary and
he was great and he grabbed a coffee and
we had a chat and and again that you
really I was really sort of struck with
the holida generosity of his time
because he didn't have to do that and
you know I'm a competitors and I've been
a competitor for anyone listening like
if you'll think like reach reach out I
couldn't yeah that that's absolutely
right what have you got to lose if
you're thinking about doing it you know
your recruiter wherever you're
specializing in and you know you also
you should know your competition
Reeth and think about set up your own
like reach out them have some
conversations cuz yeah you'll be
surprised how many people will be happy
to invest a bit of time to give you are
you sure I'm gonna like go after stuff
that you yeah yeah you know go and do it
like going you know I've loved it so so
yeah I think friends definitely just
thought yeah make it rain do want to do
and I think actually I did bounce off a
couple of subtle candidates and people I
know as well and think what do think
about if I did this and they were like
yeah go on go and do it so just bouncing
off a few people and the girlfriend just
said long as the mortgage is covered
okay obviously and then heads up has
there been challenges there in terms of
like obviously you said you said earlier
about being Bernal stuff like that cuz
now it's like it's just one of the
shoulders there's even more pressure
right so how have you found that do you
know what I've dedicated now set times
in the day where I'll make sure I'll go
to the gym and you spent all mother you
know with a mental is that really help
yeah massively helps your mental
well-being like so true linked isn't you
know healthy mind what so what would you
block out every time yeah lunchtime
every day where I can and actually
Friday afternoons I typically finish
slightly early and then I go for a swim
and and go for a jog or do something
like that
there has me making sure that you
blocked out exercise yeah really helped
literally in you know in my diary in the
you know it's one hour it's there every
single day you're gonna go and do that
that's it and if clients say can you
speak between that time I just I'll call
you after when I'm back and it's been so
helpful because it just allows me to and
that's nothing
I like that you just said that got the
temptation is oh I'll give a quick cool
and then I'll do that and then I'll do
that I'm I'm I'm I'm prone to that
really I need to be better at that cuz
like I yeah I can block in my diary I
like to just get gym done in the
mornings yeah done but yeah life but if
I block something now I'm very I'm more
prone to go yeah I'll call you then or
whatever but yeah do you need to be more
disciplined down you say well no well
that's the thing and you know first
thing in the morning like before work
starts that's a real key time to do this
head on calls yeah talk to clients when
they're traveling into work you tend to
get a lot more traction there so I've
almost utilized at that time for doing
my BD and then as I say but some lunch
codes because they want to go and have
clients in cash going at their own lunch
and do their own thing and that's my
time as well so in they're doing it why
shouldn't I so I think doing that just
allows me to have that you know
de-stress and just doing what I need to
do and then back not like that and how's
um how's the missus being with you uh
have you been on the phone a lot and
even anybody got a laptop out in the
evening have you found that LinkedIn app
on the phone that's been a nightmare
because obviously people just be pinging
you 9 10 because do you get mine back do
you get did she say mine stopped working
I'm bad so I used to the thing was like
a lamppost where I used to live and when
I'd walk from the station back to my
house I used to say but I'm I get there
I'm not doing any more calls yeah and
that that was my little Brahmas since I
moved house and stuff I've been yeah
I've been really bad that's my thing
that I've been really I wouldn't
recommend is a sec because you're
accessible linked it all the time you
can ping people
private message whatever and the
temptation just to quickly respond I'll
just quickly respond yeah
so that is bad and there's been a few
times where she's been like what you're
doing and you know the phone's on it
midnight then logically reply to this
person yeah yeah it's hard enough it's a
process just which our particular it's
your baby like you'll get when it's
yours because it matters more and
actually that drives he drives people
when it's your own thing that you're
trying to grow and develop but yeah
that's the biggest thing you can I think
there's always something that you can
find to do yeah yeah you could finish it
six o'clock yeah but you know you're
thinking ahead I could do that yeah I
could do that and then I'll go job
spotting an evening or LinkedIn I'll
click on the job and then I'll just be
scrolling or just quickly apply that
mentions that person and then yeah
before you know it you're evens good
yeah and I totally I think it's a
process so you all get better at but I
think for me what has really helped
I'm sure you may have just done this
intuitively or whatever but I've had a
lot really make sure that obviously
communicate yeah what the hell I'm doing
yeah no I mean yeah yeah good though I
could look at now if I'm near misses and
you're on LinkedIn your finest light
mine like stop texting light you know I
mean it's so easy to associate light
you're just sort of scrolling or
whatever do you know I mean yeah yeah I
think that's what's will you help me in
terms of communicating
one one doing it like this is a this
isn't as it isn't just to me yeah like
this is why did you know I mean yeah
actually helped me personally and I
think you know for anyone that's setting
up a business it you know it's my only
point it doesn't matter if it's a if
it's a lifestyle business that's why
you're doing it that's awesome
no loads people that make I've got great
businesses lifestyle if you want to grow
it like but I think before you do it
understand the reasons why you're doing
yeah if you're doing it just to be the
Leonardo DiCaprio making it rain or
whatever like that that's not that's not
a good novelty for me anyway that's not
enough reason like money I've always
have the mentality of a crewman that
money is a byproduct of success mmm if
you're successful yeah people will pay
you good salaries you'll get good
Commission that's just part of it but if
you're purely looking as a monetary
reason where you're set up on your own I
personally wouldn't set up on your own
yeah those first few months I could be
first few years are hard graft yeah you
know you're probably not going to pay so
very much you know overheads aren't too
bad depending when I get office space
but it's a big investment that bring you
said that to the next point yeah as we
sort of come to the end my howl howls
you said about biggest challenge self
motivation and staff yeah talking a bit
about it there we should be talking
about there is that the resilience piece
right yeah
how how how have you cultivated that or
what's your relationship with resilience
and how have you sort of gone through as
you said you're fully aware it's gonna
be hard graft it's tough so how have you
done that or like you know I mean how
have you what what do you do to help
with that so i I've got this thing in my
book where I've almost got like a good
thing in the day and the bad thing the
day so still interested in something
good happens I'll just do a little
Astrix and just make a quick note of it
like a quick one liner like good call
with X all or next week and if you know
I can it's turned down a job I'll be
like okay that's not great you know and
I just make a list and I don't lose
sight of the good the bad is learns but
the stuff that's good at resting is how
long we've done that I used I literally
started when I set the business up
really advice I got from one these
networking groups
like just do breakdown a sort of pros
and cons of the day and it's been so
valuable why does that be valuable
because you any recruiter always
gravitates to the negative that's
happened the day so they get a fee in
first in the morning and then you have
like three dropouts and I don't know
clients aim to go away and then you lose
sight of the good thing that happen in
the morning so I think for me almost
having that down physically on a piece
of paper every day that goes that's good
you don't you're then kind of go okay
okay this might sound you know it might
feel bad for me but I've gone all these
things today that are good you know is
one good thing no I think I feel at
least are today yeah I think yeah I
think what you're I think that's really
interesting because it is very easy to
forget where you will get or we're
salespeople were extroverts and
typically we're competitive nature
people it's really easy to gravitate or
wasting to negative so I think not
losing sight of that the little quick
wins you know they're they're the real
key things to keep you self motivated
much heavy copper final things am so six
months in yeah would you go back and do
anything differently for yeah and what a
few things that go on talk to me kind of
almost sound like I'm conscious what I
said before getting too many people's
advice so I went out that's a good point
I went out and got advice really good
advice but then I almost got went to too
many people to get advantage and then I
was getting this conflictive okay should
I be doing that or that yeah so almost
select two of you people that you trust
or you want to reach out to you know the
recruiters whatever get their advice
digest it and then execute and the next
thing I like to do but but don't don't
listen to Thomas - yeah yeah yeah
set be discipline with what you're going
to do mmm
because the temptation when you're on
your own it's just if a client says you
come on I know this isn't your normal
bar but can you go and recruit yeah I
don't know whatever the temptation say
yes to everything so true you've got to
be so disciplined when you start because
you're just yeah I'll do that and yeah
how does it say know that the beginning
is so hard I thought I picked up a job
at Boston movement in five I have a job
which was like it was just nothing to do
with what I was doing and I say yeah
yeah and I was literally like two weeks
here and hadn't found a makanda and they
were bit like what's going on I had to
say to them not I'm really sorry I've
kind of jumped the gun a bit yeah so I
think make sure your whatever you're
specializing is stay with you know stay
focused on that don't I think that the
same time be open there might change or
yeah but I think know what you don't
want to do or how you don't want to work
yeah I had my first experience this over
the last couple of weeks and I said no
for the first time yeah because they
basically proposed how they want me to
work with them right okay and it wasn't
how I've it's your way yeah I mean it
was actually like it sounded great I was
like okay yeah sure and I actually said
I sort of said yeah okay I'm open to it
blah blah blah sat down with him again I
was like I just want to make sure I'm on
the same page like what we proposed in
blah blah blah and then I was like okay
right sweet let's do it and I instantly
regretted it really yeah yeah so they're
not obviously cool them had the telling
between my legs and blättler
I know I said yes but I'll be honest
last thinking about all weekend and this
is why I can't wear like that and it was
really interesting actually because what
happened was they then basically said to
me what we do really want to work with
you like we I think it would be stupid
for you to not work there's a huge
opportunity long term Bo oblong I was
like okay that's fair enough
hmm but this is how on to work so then
I'm now working within base it's like
how I've worked with how everyone I work
with in the last four months and how I
want to work right now yeah but I what I
had I said yes and then I said no yeah I
just many more yeah if you say no people
respect you more for it yeah back in the
future because they'll go okay you're
standing by what your USP is or what
your specializing is and you know let's
touch basic in the future people aren't
gonna walk away forever I think that
sometimes in your head when you're going
yeah right it's a new job like God God
because like again it was quite a just
got it was like here and this is gonna
be a [ __ ] show yeah don't do it
yeah I've been listen to it stay yeah
and then now it's like okay we work
together and if my gut is being
completely Ryan it's not great at all
I mean I'll definitely deliver them work
with them Ben and I can learn from that
going know what guys let's Ben gray I've
delivered but I'm alright now a lot I
don't I don't want to worry anymore and
this is why yeah cuz ha it's hard at the
beginning no it's easy if you've got a
shadow des clients and those of you can
just go yeah no thank ya pick one but
you know
why yeah my guts telling me no I mean
it's hard it's so important to stand the
ground and again I've had a voice from
that like stand your ground this is what
you do be discipline and respect for
that too much of why to be careful yeah
be strict with what you what you're
willing to do Wayne not to do anything
else
listen she got mmm because I've listened
to my gut from a whole career oh I've
made loaded mistake yeah don't get me
wrong but generally listen to my gut has
got me to Connor where I am today so
I've got loads to learn still don't get
me wrong
but generally my guts been right so if
the gut doesn't feel right whether
that's a move to another recruitment
business whether that's an investment
opportunity whether that's just someone
you're hiring or whatever client you
want to take on board just if you got
says that doesn't feel right then go
with your gut yeah I like it so before
we finish me yeah one or two questions
and just because I've had quite a few
messages about recently first one
counteroffers I should go to advice
statistics recently it's quite
interesting because a few people have
said that I think the last person
Alistair said you know what they have
actually definitely been quite way more
common this year yeah they have I agree
with that yeah so that's really
interesting wise let's talk about it
because I've got quite a few messages so
hopefully because it is the typical like
if I I think now the spill that I'd give
someone if they're considering a
counteroffer is look and the jury of
people that accept the counter off will
not stay in their role why would you
accept that role and it's taken them six
months to realize that you're this
valuable to them but you know I mean
that's exactly so like what comes to
mind for you if you were trying to deal
with there's obviously only certain
amount you can do but what's your sort
of what do you think when you're had to
do with a counteroffer the situation so
there's two ways that answer I think yes
from from training up people over the
years and stuff I always say to them
have you done all your investigative
work with a canon star ie one of your
first questions for any new candidate
for a job is have you spoke to your boss
internally yeah what could I do to me
yeah how you have you qualified
everything out or have you missed a few
because cause ultimately most majority
of counteroffers are through money there
are managers in they throw money at
Thermage
to your point all why do they do that
six months ago whatever but I think at
the start of it again it's understand
from the can is it money and I always
say to cats don't worry if it is like
bit like we recruiters if you leave them
for money that's fine but we need to
know that because no one likes saying
that almost when they're talking to it
as a candidate they normally likes to
say I want to move because I want 10
grand more or they'll say Oh
a new opportunity which basically means
that so I think that's the first thing
from a recruiter to a recruiter
perspective interrogate at the start
because you'll find your counteroffer
issues will be less down the line
you're right happens like the answer
offers absolutely something there's only
so much you could do but I think just
almost understanding it because
certainly again from the the younger me
someone counteroffer me and literally
emotions in it no no no you want this no
I actually listen to them an active
listening you know talked about earlier
on don't listen to him understand what
why are they why they let me leave while
I look at the stage sorry like you know
there could be a senior role with you
know global responsibility they weren't
getting before Fair Play
like all the best but I think just
interrogating that all way through the
process particularly the star and then
every time you you're having your cannot
on interview how to go any reservations
have you spoken an internal team I'm
always really nervous when any can it
goes into process and hasn't had any
conversation with a boss that's all
about I'm a bit unhappy or I'm looking
for a new development whatever call I
like it but it hasn't in it scrap of a
question what's the best reason you've
had from a candidate that couldn't
attend an interview what comes to mind
Oh actually yeah so I had one last year
it was a dog's birthday Wow
so she yeah she literally call me the
morning she was in Menna being at nine
and I got I got a call my way into work
I literally got half an hour before and
she I'm really sorry I forgot it's my
dog's birthday I mean my husband are
taking the dog out for the day well and
what she is you placed her and she was
due to start no no no she was going into
an interview so it she was going in for
an intern at nine o'clock I'm sorry I
was going for nine o'clock into you and
a half inch cause I'm really soft course
but my husband of the day with a dog
what can you say that you can't say oh
let me say I love dogs so I'm like okay
just like really right okay I mean
England I was generally God I was just
what God smile just like well he'd like
to send me the pictures like said you
want to rearrange it yeah thank you mate
and cool slip before we finish what what
are you excited about mate six months in
what's going on in your world yeah so
exciting time for me so just got some
new offices in Sandton nice which is
awesome so sitting up there just about
to hopefully hire the first person drive
if I am to be in there yeah which is
awesome so I'm going to do an
experienced hires do you want yes I'm an
experienced guy I knew I've known for a
few years from the industry and stuff
and real sound guys yeah he's coming to
join X month which is awesome and yeah
I've just started off a talent share
referral scheme which is to a local
charity near where I live House Hospice
so we donate 200 pound of every fee if a
clan bird which is great and that and
that's one of the beauties of doing a
bit on your own you can give that may
community yeah so that's a really cool
initiative that just started out and
yeah see where the next sort of six
months ago yeah it's going well and it's
a last question asks everyone if there
if if monk could obviously communicate
to every single real crew out there they
take on an advice
they'd implement it can be a word or
phrase what do you say a word a phrase
anything be authentic nice
well you might pay for that mine it's
been a pleasure mate yeah should time
pledge okay see